ils sont arrivés pour leur tournée française
le 23 février dernier.
Le lendemain ils se réveillaient pour découvrir
avec effroi que leur pays était attaqué
par la Russie.
Les danseurs et danseuses du Québec city
ballet donnaient leur dernière représentation
de casse-noisette hier à Tours, un vrai moment
de féerie en ces temps troublés regardez
l'histoire est celle de Clara une jeune fille
qui, la veille de noël, reçoit un cadeau
de son oncle : un casse-noisettes en bois.
Le jouet se transforme en prince après avoir
combattu le roi des souris.
Les deux amoureux sont alors transportés
dans un univers magique peuplé de poupées
sous les yeux ébahis des petits et grands.
Les costumes !
(Pourquoi est ce que tu as bien aimé les
costumes ?)
Parce que les tutus ils étaient brillants
!
Les décors et les danses c'était féérique,
très très beau.
(Et même si elle boude elle a bien aimé
ou pas ?)
(rires) oui oui elle a bien aimé !
ce conte d'Hoffmann fut réadapté par Alexandre
Dumas en 1844.
C'est cette version qui a inspiré Tchaïkovski
pour composer ce ballet devenu si célèbre.
Sur scène donc une troupe de 30 artistes
ukrainiens dansant sur une musique écrite
par un russe : tout un symbole.
C'est très dur émotionnellement parce qu'on
doit faire bonne figure sur scène et sourire
mais on est des professionnels et on doit
faire avec.
Malheureusement aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
rentrer chez nous en Ukraine.
C'est un véritable défi quotidien car tout
le monde est très stressé.
On ne dort pas beaucoup et c'est très difficile
de garder le moral, aller sur scène, répéter,
danser alors que tout est si sombre
En résidence au théâtre du châtelet à
Paris depuis le 23 février, il s'agissait
de la dernière représentation de Casse-Noisette
en France par le Kiev city ballet.